just got a big Wormhole of some of the
episodes like just the dark things that
you cover like are you ever like I need
a break from the murder and the cyanide
and Tylenol we're talking about the
Tylenol Motors it was just an episode
where someone just basically injected
Tylenol into random bottles of Tylenol
it was in Chicago cyanide tyen Chicago
yep and just like drugstores whatever
just it was back when they didn't have
the safety seals on bottles and it was
just all capsules and so they would just
you know uh take apart the capsule dump
out the Tylenol powder and replace it
with um I think it was potassium Cyanide
and then beyond lethal like these people
would die within hours but it is crazy
where it's like any a 5-year-old uh
80-year-old anyone baby well I guess
weird to give a baby Extra Strength TY
but like almost anybody but I think on
that stuff it's like I just finally
accepted like or maybe understand more
what uh truce you know sociopathy or
sociopathy I think is how that one is
and when those those people when they
truly like chemically have no empathy
and no care for others there's nothing
they can't like I feel like I've studied
evil so much at this point yeah it's
almost become Bolin in some ways where
I'm like yep that's just what people
like that do they don't care they don't
care if it's a baby they don't care if
it's an 80-year-old because they truly
at a core level do not care about other
humans they only care about consequences
of being caught for doing bad things
because that would affect them when were
the Tylenol murders that was
198 was fascinated listening because it
was like he did all these very uh
Sinister kind of things that were clever
and you know whatever and then when
called to Blackmail was like send me a
million dollars you're like right right
it's like a weird cartoon amount of like
just like yeah ask for for Tylenol ask
for 50 right this huge company yeah like
I just got obsessed with the amount of
money like I was like trying to figure
out his psyche of like is a million like
the amount that he could probably get
away with and like I just am like you
probably could have gotten more homie
but also getting caught in such a dumb
way to well that guy just wanted to
frame his that what was so weird about
that suspect and I can't remember his
name right now is that he did I mean it
looks like he probably was the Tylenol
murderer and gets all these innocent
people killed just because his wife one
check bounced like the the the guy who
hired his wife the company goes under
the travel agency goes under and the
final check to her bounces and that was
enough for This Woman's husband to be
like Oh I'm going to ruin you and then
he just like dedicates his life first he
wants to she worked for Tylenol cuz she
wor no she worked for this random travel
agency and so the Tylenol was just a
random thing it was just because he knew
that's a good way to poison people what
he wanted to do was uh kill people and
then set this guy who owned the travel
agency up for that murder make it look
like it was him and make it look like it
was him trying to Blackmail
Tylenol uh James Lewis I think that was
the guy yeah yeah that suspect and then
that guy also I also love people this
serial killer sociopath was happily
married and I'm not oh that's what
drives me the most nuts about some of
these stories the P Pismo Beach killer
right kills all these Craigslist
prostitutes da d da and his wife had no
idea which means he was like a lovely
husband in Happily he can figure out how
to make a relationship work and I can't
well if you don't if you don't care if
you're not ruled by emotion if you're
like a robot inside that um you know is
is not affected I think I just there was
like a little fruit FL I think I just
ate it as did you just eat a bu think so
I think I I was flying and I so we could
make sure to go through and play it back
in slow motion I think I just ate it oh
all
right and that was perfect it didn't get
back of the throat I like like I'm a
lizard and then just keep talking wait
are you sure do you want some water no
it didn't it was like the perfect just
gone but but these these guys they can
compartmentalize have a family go to
kids softball games it's it's why a fair
amount of like CEOs I guess also test
really high as far as like this
sociopath scale because I'm like how
much easier would it be to have live
with the fact that you're paying people
$10 you have to reduce you have to
dehumanize people and go well if we just
pay them $8 an hour and if we just make
it so that Amazon drivers have to in a
bag you know you know and then if we
just time them right and they lose money
if they you know stop and pee then like
they have to think in terms of human
beings are just numbers exactly and I
think in a weird way with all this that
our obsession with True Crime and like
Hitler and these terrible people is
actually really healthy I think we're
obsessed because we don't understand why
they could do those things how they
could do because we're not like that
like how much more up would it be if
that stuff was just boring to all of us
yeah you know or just like well yeah of
course I mean if I had the chance I
would kill a bunch of people too I me of
course I would yeah it would be our
vision board it would be inso yeah we
all think like that and I think there's
like the the rubbernecking 101 of the
reason we rubber neck is like to study
it so that we can figure out and like
try to have some monom of control and to
go like okay here's the common
denominator and all C people right
they're not going to get me because I've
been studying these things I think why
women are more fascinated by
statistically serial killers and stuff
than men yeah we're studying yeah
studying how do I avoid I mean most of
serial killers are men who Target women
you know there's way more violence
towards women than there is towards men
so I think it's a self-preservation
Instinct of like I'm going to study I'm
going to feel like okay you got to lock
door don't date a guy with an ice pick
don't date a guy with a general rule
yeah look for these red flags and like
you're asking like these questions like
what common denominators it's like it
makes sense to have these Curiosities
because it's like then I can look for
that those red flags and somebody that I
might be dating or that I might meet or
you know bef friend and then I'll know
so that doesn't happen to me MH so yeah
some people get like worried like some
moralists about like how up our culture
is you know being interested in these
things it's like no it's a very healthy
thing to be fascinated by this stuff